hey babies it's episode 162 of
congratulations what's up my baby's life
friggin rips that's why I've got the
life Rip's hoodie on I decided to wear
it today because life frigging rips dude
it does man and you just got to remain
only thing you got to do to understand
about life rips is maybe you're in a bad
mood
just [ __ ] remember life rips remember
it just remember all you guys do is
member so yeah man still can't hear out
of my left ear all good so disrespectful
how [ __ ] in one fire said I have hearing
and I literally said I have a [ __ ]
hearing issue last episode and I feel
like I maybe do and it's already hot and
it's already hot my babies
I'm already feels like it's [ __ ] 92
degrees anyway yeah man so we got let's
see it's this is episode 1 some [ __ ]
[ __ ] and we got torque let me just go
over these here I added two shows to the
West Palm Beach Florida those are coming
up in a few weeks and they're they'll
sell out for sure Robinson Mississippi
some reason Rohnert Park California
where is it I'll be in Las Vegas Nevada
for two nights and also two nights after
that so that's four nights but we say it
like that I'm there for two nights and
two nights because it's not four nights
in a row it's two nights in April and
tonight's in August and dude this is a
announcement here an announcement here
for this is the first ever now babies
get ready because Friday at 10:00 a.m.
either Eastern or some other time I
don't care just whenever it is look at
my website the first congratulations
podcast live is happening ever so you
can get tickets there's about I think
1,200 tickets it's in Los Angeles
and you won't
you know I think it'll sell out in
[ __ ] minutes we're gonna have a bunch
of surprises there we're gonna have
maybe who knows maybe we'll have some
guests or whatever but we'll be doing
the you know it won't be stand-up comedy
I'll be sitting down me doing the
[ __ ] podcast and that frankly is
sensation so it's all good my babies and
I can't wait to do that man
and if it's good who knows maybe we'll
do [ __ ] more but maybe we won't maybe
this will be the only time that we ever
do congratulations podcast live so if
you are coming Friday the tickets go on
sale get the tickets where your merch
it's okay if you don't have the [ __ ]
hoodies and [ __ ] but if you have them
brang you understand because it's gonna
be a real life cult meeting dude a real
life meeting of the cult dude sensation
and that's just [ __ ] a wonderful man
sensational we slowed it down for you
dude we chopped and screwed it like they
do in [ __ ] Louisiana anyway so we're
doing the live congratulations podcast
[ __ ] it we'll do it live dude what's a
guy's name Bill O'Reilly
hi mr. O'Reilly who says that is Eminem
I don't even know maybe I just made it
Eminem and it's not I know you know what
it's not it's ludicrous that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
hi mr. O'Reilly that's who it is
um anyway um [ __ ] one fire just typed
in Luda sir Luda Luda sir
so that's why I won't fire it's a little
crisp but if I typed in Luda sir so it's
all good yes typos dude typos on top of
typos because Ludacris is already a typo
because rappers can't spell [ __ ] right
may 7th prey improv I'll be there for
two weekends in a row
well [ __ ] my jo koy uh and in
Atlantic City we got to do that one man
that one's gonna be that's selling very
well it's in August or we know it's in
July but it's already selling very well
who knew you know yeah boy [ __ ] who
knew dude your boys I had to get
but yeah Netflix is a joke is the actual
Netflix is the it's a Netflix festival
we're doing their congratulations
podcast for which is cool so it's
brought to you by me and Netflix and
that's that's gonna be amazing they have
a great lineup there for every every but
I think I think two bears one cave is
doing it too
and there are other comedians that are
doing it like Ali Wong and [ __ ] like
that so it'll be awesome and it's in LA
and if you don't live in LA do it feel
sorry for you that week because it'll be
[ __ ] awesome anyway uh what's up do
you guys have the [ __ ] coronavirus
yet is anybody listening to this that
has a corona virus I only fist bump dude
I fist bump period but now when somebody
wants to shake my hand I legitimately
want to be like the [ __ ] is your deal
and not because shaking hands is a bad
thing I think I'm gonna get the corona
virus if I shake someone's hand but I
think I might get the corona virus if I
shake everybody's hand and guess who's
guess who's shaking everybody's hand if
I'm out in public I'm gonna [ __ ]
shake everybody's hand because people
are [ __ ] saying [ __ ] oh hey Chris oh
hey Chris that's looking for crappy
Budaj edge dude if I'm out in LA I'm
peoplewe de jedge you understand people
want to shake your boy's hand so I gotta
[ __ ] do a fist bump and then still
people who look at me like oh okay well
we're okay and don't wanna shake hands
yeah dude cuz I gotta shake [ __ ]
everybody's hand cuz I'm not getting the
[ __ ] rona virus dude Corona
that's so dick for the fight that's so
shitty for the beer company you know
that it's called the corona virus as I
calling it the [ __ ] Bud Light virus
like it's just the whoever recruit
coined the term they just [ __ ] over a
Corona the beer you know there's frat
guys out there that's just that are like
dude I've been [ __ ] it I've had the
corona virus for years dawg just
drinking a [ __ ] Corona you take your
corona virus with lime it's classic
there isn't more of a [ __ ] crack guy
thing to say than classic when
something's not classic no doubt dude
sick dude coronavirus dude I've had the
[ __ ] coronavirus for years dog Oh
when a white guy cause another [ __ ]
white guy dog you know uh yeah so anyway
but do you have the kernel virus if you
do I really want to hear about it so
just tweet me so I can [ __ ] now look
at it you know uh it's [ __ ] I guess
the the kill rate is like two three
percent and the flu is like point one or
something I think it's not I think it's
worse than the flu that's what I heard
there's one buddy Dan said but you know
what dude I'm done trust and Dan yeah
I'm done trust and Dan yes dude I won't
trust him anymore
you know why he's a [ __ ] liar and you
know why he's a liar this is the [ __ ]
man that is important to me when
somebody [ __ ] says here's what
happened and I put it on my Instagram
it's my last Instagram post but if you
listen to this in a few days it's
probably not my last Instagram post so
go back a few my buddy Dan goes like
this let me just try to [ __ ] lay it
out in the most basic of terms okay my
buddy Dan says for no reason you know
what's supposed to rain tomorrow and I
go and I say oh cool and then he says
yup and then we just keep drinking
coffee because that's all I do is drink
coffee all [ __ ] day long and when
people say well maybe that's why you
have restless leg syndrome I get [ __ ]
pissed off because that's not gonna stop
and also that's not why because I've
done [ __ ] you know testing for it
I've had a control and a [ __ ]
whatever the other thing I'm the science
but I do testing for my restless leg
syndrome you know what helps restless
leg syndrome for real bustin or not
sensation anyway my buddy do it and
here's why man because he [ __ ] goes
like this it's gonna rain tomorrow and I
said yeah he said yup and then we just
kept drinking that coffee alright
and then he goes and then and that's it
and that's [ __ ] it later on in the
night we were walking down sunset going
to get something to [ __ ] eat or
something I don't remember maybe we were
getting another coffee because I'll get
two coffees in a [ __ ] row dude I'll
go to one cafe get a coffee drink half
of it bring it to the next spot and then
drink another [ __ ] coffee anyway I
don't remember what coffee shall be
right but we were walking to another one
probably okay and I zip up my [ __ ]
jacket and I say kind of [ __ ] I got
[ __ ] cold out didn't it and he said I
told you was gonna get cold and I go
like this I lean back like a teacher
proud of his student but you know
there's something else going on - like
maybe they [ __ ] cheated that's how I
look at him and I say oh yeah and he
says yeah I said it and I said well when
just say that and he said I said it was
gonna rain tomorrow
we broke the microphone on that one man
that was a [ __ ] mic break that we're
didn't even come from dude over here Dan
made me break my microphone dude
dude [ __ ] legit okay now this [ __ ]
drives me bananas dude I'm [ __ ] ba na
na ass right now and he goes and I said
oh well that's different dude well
that's different
and he said and he was trying to act
like because he said it was gonna rain
the next day that it was gonna get cold
tonight and he said he said it dude and
he said he said it and I got so mad at
him and I said
we're done dude we're done you've moved
from my [ __ ] like seventh best friend
down to my [ __ ] like 36th best friend
and that's enemy territory because I
don't even have really 36 friends
I've got like 25 friends and then you
know it's like that Venn diagram where
it's like oh yeah but you're also my
enemy in a way he's in the middle there
so then I posted up a [ __ ] Instagram
video and I explained this and then he
come he comments this [ __ ]
this is what he comments hey people
guess what this is what he says first of
all I says hey people like his [ __ ]
Kevin Hart guess what it's [ __ ] rain
last night and it dropped 32 group and
it dropped 20 degrees like I said it
would the first time Chris Lee doesn't
remember this because he's perpetually
distracted therefore has the memory of a
flea and here goes accusing me of lying
I will be okay yeah so he's gonna sue me
ha jokes and [ __ ] people feel some dents
I get it it's actually funny they says
all this and then and then he [ __ ]
right here it's some guy says rain can
come with a cold front mr. D'Elia
usually I like a rants but this one was
dumb and I wrote way to make it serious
buddy
also that's not he didn't say it was
gonna rain so that's what's up anyway
then Dan writes yeah see whoever this
Dan guys remember saying it's gonna rain
and The Temper is gonna drop 20 degrees
like you're saying too but the Chris
D'Elia guy doesn't remember the
temperature part because he usually was
only half listening and they gets mad at
people later on for making [ __ ] up okay
dude well fine
well then why then later on that night
dude why later on that night didn't you
bring that up dude why didn't you bring
that up later on that night was I not
listening then because then I was in
full throttle full throttle heated mode
I listen when I'm in full throttle
heated mode so now who's making [ __ ] up
a day later and I know some of you see
here's the deal this is exactly what the
congratulations podcast is about it's
about San Chu Maine all right and it's
about [ __ ] learning these types of
things now this is what NPR should be
talking about why these kinds of things
happen but instead they're literally
talking about like the economy
global issues okay this is the important
[ __ ] this is congratulations podcast to
a tea now I don't remember what I was
gonna say in the beginning of that
sentence and it doesn't matter that's
also what congratulations podcasters to
the tea but I'm [ __ ] pissed dude and
now he's my thirty-six friend and it
crosses over into enemy territory yeah
dude it's just it's just I don't know
why that [ __ ] is always driving me and
driven me nuts those kinds of things
that's not what you said but that's not
what you said I can't believe how many
times I've said but that's not what you
said in my life dude
I've said but that's not what you said
more times than Vince Vaughn has said it
mmm no doubt so that's it we got too
many liquids on here we got a [ __ ]
ice americano
we got a 40 ounce of water that shout
out to my boy Theo Rossi with the
company and then we got to look Froy and
then we got a [ __ ] anyway I said we
have a nicer Americano but that's too
many drinks my buddy I ripped my Irish
buddy at drink has so many drinks on him
all the time
he always has a [ __ ] coffee water and
an actual drink like a [ __ ] like a
drink drink with alcohol in it bro
figure it out it got two hands he'll you
Goro that's a [ __ ] slam and that's a
[ __ ] slam who you Goro um anyway man
my pitcher sweating so hard it's crazy
it's like they film [ __ ] Jumanji
under my armpits I cannot believe he did
that dude that was the first [ __ ] by
the way that was the first microphone
swing away [ __ ] come back boomerang
that I've ever done and he deserved it
dude anyway don't get the curve right
here's the deal
my buddies all so scared about the
corner virus he's like I always think
stuff is like not gonna hit us and [ __ ]
like that but the corona virus is very
very what do you call what's the
contagious and then and then I was like
oh yeah and he said cuz somebody got it
in like Northern California and they
weren't even they didn't even go
anywhere on an airplane si okay so it's
very catchable that
my babies so anyway we're those masks I
can't wait to go to West Palm Beach next
week next month and wear the [ __ ]
mask for real and be like one of those
Asians the Asians been wearing masks
dude mass doesn't help that's what I
haven't get rid of says and I'm not
gonna wear the mask then get the corona
virus and enemy they were more madder
Ivan katroo I wear a mask but I'm not
gonna wear that mask I'm gonna wear one
of those [ __ ] Richard Nixon masks
they gonna be like what is this Point
Break I'm gonna wear a [ __ ] Richard
Nixon mess and when people go like sir
white wearing the mask and I go like
this perón walrus sir you here to rob a
bank
no I just want to get to Corona waters
and then they say but well why don't you
just wear I say look I'm not Asian I'm a
white boy
huijin's only wear those masks like
their dentist or some [ __ ]
isn't it funny though what the agents
come over here and there are actually
our dentist mm-hmm because I used to
want to walk to walk up to those people
when the coronavirus wasn't a thing and
I wanted to be like can you clean my
teeth I wanted to walk up to those
people I just go like this
ah and when they say what are you doing
and I say well what do you mean what am
i doing we're obviously in a dentist's
office and you're going to clean my
teeth because if your masks on I just
want to flip I want my brain to break
I'm so close to having my brain just and
start doing that [ __ ] and I'm gonna and
I can't wait dude I think once I turned
50 it's on I know we got a [ __ ] like
I'm the youngest man alive at this point
but I when we get to 50 and when I say
we because I mean you all y'all
[ __ ] are coming with me dude
when I say we disposable ear loop face
masks dude the fact that the it loops
around the ear it just makes me feel
like we're dumb humans you know like the
fact that they were like that some like
literally anybody was like
have ears and they just effect I've
always thought this that they scoop
around the ears is just so dumb you know
like they're like we'll just put it
behind the ears
classic anyways like 3,000 people died
from the corona virus and if you're one
of them
well you're not listening so um but a
guy came up to me and goes like this
fist bumps he goes to have the fist bump
and he goes corona hey guy you don't
have to explain why you're being a
[ __ ] jackass
just be a jackass with me Corona hey man
Corona Corona hi Corona nice to meet you
um one time a guy introduced himself to
me and he goes like this hey I say hey
I'm Chris and he says seven oh your
robot dude his name was seven I remember
was at the [ __ ] diner in Burbank what
the hell's that place called his name
was seven I said seven and he said yeah
and then I didn't do any jokes as he
heard them all for sure that's you know
did you see the [ __ ] KFC donut the
chicken with the donut the KFC KFC
chicken donut they just put them all
together now doughnut sandwich new fried
chicken dish
don't call it a dish dude you know it's
a [ __ ] cancer sandwich the new dish
from KFC bro Kentucky for
chicken a doughnut served hot imagine
eating imagine how much for real you
gotta [ __ ] yourself
imagine eating that sandwich and then
also drinking a coffee and then just
having it Wow
you're you would take a [ __ ] and your
[ __ ] would sound like Colin Firth in
King's Speech it would just come out
like do your [ __ ] would just be
people from the other room outside of
the bathroom would be like is he
watching King's Speech
[Laughter]
oh I realized something too man I was
watching the Macmillan's documentary
dude
you're not a dork if you just laugh so
much yes I figured it out dude all you
got to do is laugh at everything always
and you're not a dork you're not corny
you're not anything but [ __ ] awesome
I realized it the guy in the Macmillan's
documentary is an FBI agent and he is
his name's like Doug something and he's
so dorky but he just laughs at
everything and it makes him so not dorky
because he doesn't give a [ __ ] look
they're calling him a breakout star what
millions breakups our FBI agent Doug
Matthews thinks of the McDonald's fraud
doc Doug Matthews dude is [ __ ] he's an
FBI dude he's a special agent and he's
like yeah they were doing this one gig
where you know we're trying to find this
one thing out and I didn't care I don't
always boring and so I saw this one
thing and he just goes and then you're
like oh my god dude
wait go go back up
yeah dude bro Doug Matthews is the
[ __ ] [ __ ] when he laughs he looks so
British running laughs oh ho ho ho he
looks like he's gonna be like that dude
this guy as soon as he gets
she's good to [ __ ] in weekend this is it
describes I don't know this is on a
Houston website or some [ __ ]
described as lightning in a bottle
Hernandez and I never wild character
they love him into work ever as soon as
he got on the phone it was like when can
I come to Jacksonville and see you guys
Hernandez dude he wasn't in he wasn't an
undercover agent he was a regular FBI
agent he was always trying to go
undercover for like he was always trying
to go undercover for like things that
you didn't need to go undercover for
they be like hey can you grab me a straw
for my [ __ ] thing and be like sure
let me get the glasses and you're like
no just we're at [ __ ] Starbucks and
you just draw for my marcano and they'd
be like Oh anyway yeah let me get my
moustache and glasses I gotta go get
some [ __ ] sugar for your coffee no
just do it it's fine if you're Doug
Mathews so finally this if you haven't
seen millions which is really [ __ ] a
crazy documentary I don't know I don't
think all of the episodes aired yet but
I've only seen like two or three and
they show it's about the McDonald's when
they did monopoly there was like fraud
and people were like selling tickets and
the FBI tried to find out who they who
these people were and they took the next
winner and they went undercover as a
documentary team from McDonald's that
was like film in his experience and this
guy goes like this
Doug what is it Matthew's he says well
I'm gonna go undercover and and I want
to do the documentary crew and I want to
be the director and the reason why I
want to be the director is because
directors
he says it's cuz everybody knows
directors don't do [ __ ] he's an FBI
agent
directors do hey Doug Matthews
directors do the whole thing you know so
I loved him immediately dude oh god he's
funny and anyway so he is he would be a
dork if he wasn't laughing but because
he's laughing and doesn't give a [ __ ]
about this [ __ ] he truly is just the
[ __ ] so I figured it out man I figured
it out so that's what I'm gonna do from
now on when anybody makes fun of
anything what I wear
what I wear they're like oh you're too
too old which is ridiculous dude I mean
bro I'm old are you kidding me
I can practically can't roll over yet
that's how young I am I'm so young my
poop is yellow bro I'm so um actually
it's not even yellow it looks at the
[ __ ] La Brea Tar Pits man because
that's what comes out when you [ __ ]
first ivory like for the first few days
because you still were eating the stuff
from your mommy's placenta sensation did
you know that when babies come out and I
know that because you know you know why
I know that now because well my life's a
little different than it was last week
was isn't it and it's because [ __ ]
babies [ __ ] out their mommy's placenta
stuff and that's the scientific term of
it uh and when they do it looks like the
La Brea Tar Pits for a few days and then
the poop comes out yellow yellow dude
the yellow it looks yellow like some
[ __ ] that like [ __ ] somebody would
slip and fall in and then a week later
become a Marvel superhero that's how it
looks
it's baby [ __ ] man oh no here's baby
[ __ ] man what happened to him he slipped
and fell in some baby [ __ ] you know it's
bright yellow oh yeah and then that
would be [ __ ] in real life and then I
would try to do it and I would just get
pinkeye so anyway adds better help
mm-hmm is there something interfering
with your happiness or preventing you
from achieving your goals now I've
fallen victim to this okay I'm good now
you you know cuz life rips but I've
fallen victim of this to this weather
it's been because of sleep whether it's
been because of stress or anxiety
especially that's me but better help
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist it's very cool man you can
start communicating in under 24 hours so
if you need help now do it now and
within 24 hours you'd be talking to
someone it's not a crisis line it's not
a self-help line it's professional
counseling done securely online it's
very legit
broad range of expertise in better helps
counselor network which may not be
locally available in many areas the
service is available for clients
worldwide ok it's committed better help
is committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if needed
visit better help calm / Congrats and
join over 500,000 people talk
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
congratulations listeners get 10% off
your first month that better help calm
Congrats hey man I think this is a great
thing is to is to make sure you're
mentally in check and taking care
yourself you take care of your car every
few months why don't you take care of
yourself too that's your brain power dot
I got it on right now and look being fit
and healthy is the goal I love being fit
I like eating right and I like being
healthy I like making room for my body
is good but being sore or in pain from
workouts sucks I like my body to be
rested and well taken care of and here's
how part of the way I do it you could
spend a ton of money to hire a personal
masseuse or you could do what I did and
check out power dot I use it all the
time
peridot puts a modern spin on a
clinically proven muscle stimulation the
first of its kind power dot is built
around an intuitive mobile app which I
just have it right here and it's very
easy to use you just click around you
pick what you want and then it activates
the these strips here and it speeds up
recovery it improves athletics
performance reduces pain and it rehabs
you from injuries it's great you put
whatever you want on your body you put
it on your forearm I have a little bit
of forum pain here so I like to put it
there or your lower back and it works
everywhere you can put it wherever you
want your calves it's good for my
restless leg syndrome and you were
traveling with peridot is extremely
convenient it's so small as you can see
but peridot offers us customers a free
30 day trial plus an additional 20% off
for our listeners go to power dot-com /
Congrats and use the code congrats at
checkout for 20% off your order that's
power dot-com / Congrats and the code
congrats for 20% off very cool man but
yeah dude ugh drew math whatever the
[ __ ] his name is man
thank god there's an FBI that's just the
agent that just does that kind of [ __ ]
started over the [ __ ] timer one fire
we don't know how long we've been in a
it's 25 minutes but he's making it up
making it up dude
is 26 30 oh I didn't get rid of dude Wow
Ivan's good riddle goes like this
well actually it's that 26 30,000 and 25
25 would be way different a minute I
have different all right whatever dude
it's fine man it's all good but Yuri
cleared it cuz what happens is here is a
little BTS on the [ __ ]
behind-the-scenes of congratulations
podcast never mind it's not important
but what is important now I [ __ ] just
remember BTS is that a [ __ ] Asian
group alright dude hey are they video
games I've got a question for you BTS
are you video games the only reason why
I asked that is because you look like
people on Final Fantasy you don't look
like actual people you look like when
you move it goes oh god that's all
did you see oh my I don't and I know
their fan base is voracious and they
[ __ ] with you and they're so angry at
you if you make fun of them and I just
want you to know plain and simple and
very clearly I don't give a [ __ ] you
understand me do you feel me saying that
first of all BTS well the first of all
is they look like video games period
they look like actual video game
characters they would be like where they
would be like hello would you like to
talk to me and you're just like what
would you like to talk to me about the
village
I'm sure where can I find the disk well
all I know is Jeremy's been talking
about it for a long time you might want
to check with him how many times has
ever
one in the group bTW I said this you
might want to check with him he was
acting kind of strange I'm not sure but
Jeremy was acting kind of strange you
might want to talk to the stork through
now how many times I'm [ __ ] BTS how
many members of BTS are there how many
human members in South Park where the
guy goes human that's also funny but
goddamn their video games dude I how
were there they already have a plastic
surgery right aren't they like 12 or are
they like have they been around for a
long time
oh this video episode on wow they could
dance though huh but that's because
they're animated dude there's this one
video that this guy keeps I think it's
Brendon Walsh um let me see yeah I think
it's him it's so funny he's my favorite
got to follow on Twitter Malibu
oh it's Brendon Walsh Malibu Brendon and
he keeps tweeting the BTS he calls the
BTS salami biting fake out and first of
all was on Fallon tonight I guess we're
one of the guys but he looks like a
video game dude we're ago he pretends to
bite a huge piece of salami and then
doesn't and like gives the camera wide
eyes like he faked him out and Malibu
Brendon Brendon water which is Brendon
Walsh's comedian he's hilarious and then
you're right forget about the
coronavirus watching BTS boy prank by
the salami is infectious have a salami
I have salami fever and he's done like
40 of these knock knock who's there I'm
gonna bite the salami I'm gonna bite
this salami who Jake hey I'm not gonna
bite the salami lol I thought you were
gonna bite it I know I tricked you
ha BTS salami biting fake out you got to
look at these they're really funny but
the one that made me laugh so hard is
probably the first one he does not bite
that salami in this video but if any
salami 's get bitten in the future he
will be the prime suspect right and
that's number 25 and he writes
one-fourth of the way to one hundred
tweets about this BTS salami biting fake
out Jim dude I think he's the funniest
guy on Twitter it might it might be Rob
Delaney I mean that guy's been killer
for a long time but [ __ ] [ __ ] man
like the fact that he's going so hard in
the paint from this [ __ ] thing the
guy from BTS I hope he's seen he's
probably I'll [ __ ] I mean he looks like
a video game look at here here's another
one if you watch closely it looks like
he's definitely about to bite that
salami but at the last minute he stops
and moves a salami away from his face
the question is was his plan in advance
there was a done spot oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
the one that I laughed so hard at was
the one I think i retweeted it how do I
get to my own Twitter said said dad I
wrote I wrote this is the funniest got
into it I've read in five years oh this
one was my favorite one for sure then
number seven the director is like the
director is like salami biting scene
take one action wait cut cut cut
don't bite that salami and the doom and
the dude is like as you [ __ ]
as you wish really put me over the top
man what I don't the legit I when I
first saw this is how I learned who BTS
was by the way I thought eyelid [ __ ]
that this was a video game why are they
being video games I want to be a video
game you might want to talk to the stork
they need to make a [ __ ] song called
you might want to talk to the stork
let's listen let's watch a [ __ ]
YouTube video of them I bet I can't but
I will though but I don't want to get
demonetised but I will though enough for
a little bit
well BTS you might want to talk to this
stork here we go I'm just gonna play
[Music]
Wow sir game show
that's a [ __ ] song or a theme song
hey here we are welcome back to you
might want to talk to the stork we've
got a stork here do we get the chance to
talk to the store really get the chances
of Tom there's a question are these
people video games um I uh I would say
yes let's check with a stork Brock
yep their video games you might want to
talk to the stork with your [ __ ] host
have you seen the cat in there with your
[ __ ] host um wow dude that's so
annoying oh god they're so annoying
those [ __ ] automatic things when you
when you when you call someone I'm
trying to help just have a [ __ ]
person until you until it's
indistinguishable hmm I didn't quite get
that hmm I didn't quite I didn't quite
understand you hmm
hey there is no [ __ ] reason for a
robot to go hmm we all know we're
talking to a robot so just get right to
the goddamn sentence
hmm I didn't quite get that why is the
robot stuttering why did you program the
robot to stutter
hmm I didn't quite get that you might
want to talk to the stork all I know is
the stork was acting strange all I know
is the troglodyte was acting strange
post mates baby when you need red wine
at 4 p.m. sushi at 9 p.m. a breakfast
burrito at 8 a.m. and ibuprofen at 10
a.m. it's a drunk how said breakfast
burrito post made a baby's post mates is
your personal food delivery grocery
delivery whatever kind of delivery sort
of service all year round anything
you're craving post mates can deliver to
the largest on-demand network in the US
and offer delivery from all the
restaurants
grocery and convenience stores and
traditional retailers you could possibly
want to eat 24 hours a day 365 days a
year
you better believe if there were 400 is
here post mates would be on it 400 days
a year
no more trips to the store you can be
just killing and you don't even know
where the store is dude
post pics will deliver anything to you
download the app get post mates for a
limited time post mates is giving our
listeners $100 of free delivery credit
for your first 7 days to start your free
deliveries download the app and use code
Congrats
that's code congrats for $100 of free
delivery credit and your first 7 days
when you download the post mates app
anything you need anytime you need it
post mate it download post mates and
save with code congrats man that was
some marc bloch hair [ __ ] um me undies
dude I wear me undies and bro I wear me
undies all the time and I'm not lying to
you like Bobby Lee dude I took a pic
with Bobby Lee he pulled on his pants he
had like etnies on or whatever the hell
it was
I wear me on these all the time I got
them on now if I'm not wearing up me
undies I'm free-balling it do you
understand
they're the most comfortable underwears
ever why would you need it right now
let's let's just break this down why
would you need an undo membership
honestly I will tell you right now
because it's fun and you got to commit
to something it's an easy way to give
your future self oppressing each month a
membership with me undies is full of
perks like site-wide savings early
access free shipping and new
ridiculously soft undies delivered to
your door each month building your under
collection mixing making make sure adult
life just a tad easier more on these
equals less laundry and that's his
science man me undies has a great offer
for my listeners for any first-time
purchasers you get 15% off and free
shipping this is a no-brainer especially
because they have like a hundred percent
they have they have not like they have a
hundreds 100% satisfaction guarantee
to get you 15% off your first pair free
shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee go to my undies
comm / Congrats that's my undies comm /
congrats marc bloch here
work block here my tattoo is yes um
anyway dude Wow Bryan Callen called me
jo koy called me name dropping man name
dropping city dude
Oh name dropping city anyway
yeah BTS looks like videogames and they
know it that McDonald's doc you got to
see it dude that guy is just awesome
mm-hmm I gotta grow I don't remember who
I was talking to this was recent this is
this this week I'm like they were saying
something like yeah oh that I'm not
gonna say who was cuz he's a buddy of
mine and I love him but he's like dude
got a place out and [ __ ] the desert I
was like hey what and he said yeah I
bought a home out in the desert it's not
even barely a home it's like a [ __ ]
little can that like I just decorated I
said yeah and he said yep any time you
want to go and in my head I went whoa
whoa whoa let me stop you right there
I'm Chris D'Elia did you think maybe you
were talking to someone else did you for
a second think I was the Fisher King so
he said yeah you know and I just gonna
go out there sometimes just to unplug
let me ask you a question man this is
the thing and it's been around for a
long time ever since we've like invented
a microwave why do people need to
[ __ ] unplug I truly think if you're
someone who values unplugging you're
like a drama queen drama King not
level-headed insane person he said it he
said
[Applause]
why do you need to unplug dude what's up
dude what's going on with that you
plugged in is that what it is you
plugged in too much when people are like
God you know what I'm so glad I left my
phone at home it felt great just walking
around unplugging it felt great
just being out camping in the middle of
nowhere next to a creek I just had to
unplug even for a few days and now I
feel recharged dude you know what
recharge is you a salad a burger you
don't have to [ __ ] sleep on twigs to
unplug that's a [ __ ] new I guess
Western [ __ ] philosophy thing where
it's like we have it so goddamn good
that you just can't have it good you're
your [ __ ] guilt you we have it so
good we invented walls we invented
microwaves there's a toaster out there
dude you could put your bread that we
manufactured by the way in a toaster and
turn it into hot bread that's better and
because we've got it that good you think
you gotta unplug and be away from the
toaster so you can recharge and be a
stress-free better person well let me
tell you something guy who does that
you're just terrible at base at base
you're terrible you don't need to unplug
you can go on vacation fine experience
another thing cool go to Hawaii
go to [ __ ] Bali lay in a hot butt
sleep in a bedroom man you know why cuz
we made bedrooms and it took us so many
[ __ ] centuries and and and thousands
and thousands million what do you called
millennium millet millenias millenniums
whatever the [ __ ] that goddamn word is
that part millennia you know we [ __ ]
spend thousand
thousands of years coming up with these
impossible thread thread counts man and
you're gonna go lay on a [ __ ] rock
you just don't get how to be man I get
art Millenia
that's what it is and I get how our eyes
are adjusting because now we're looking
at [ __ ] closed screens all the time
and our eye sights are worse than it was
but dude adapt like the [ __ ] tadpole
man you're not a tadpole you're a frog
and that's a beautiful thing you think
the Frog is ever like a man I hate these
legs no they're just jumping from lily
pad to lily pad going ribbit enjoying
their frog sense enjoy your human [ __ ]
man [ __ ] unplugging I don't trust
anybody one plugs plug in I'm plugged in
all the time dude you know where my
phone is
ever here you know wherever my phone is
you know what I've never lost my phone I
lost my phone one time it was in like
2008 and I'll never lose it again
because I've been plugged in since then
I [ __ ] left a diner at the goddamn
standard hotel downtown and I left and I
walked back and it wasn't there and that
was one of my favorite phones it was one
of those ones that [ __ ] slides out
like that
and it looked like you were in the
matrix but whatever man I've been
plugged in ever since and some [ __ ]
jackass was talking to me for some
reason so long no man I was in no way it
wasn't 2008 that was like iPhone [ __ ] it
was like 2002 anyway it doesn't matter
when did the cell phone start you have
is a 2003 in August 2000 nineteen in
August 1999 everybody got a cell phone I
left I went to Vancouver to shoot a
movie came back everyone had a cell
phone and everyone was playing snake um
yeah dude I you can't trust these people
who say they unplug you just can't you
can't trust them with like secrets bro
you're gonna go unplug and change that's
the thing man
you've become who you are and anytime
you shift that like one time I was going
out with this chick and she's like hey I
bought a chick I bought a an airplane
ticket to Paris I'm just gonna go for
two weeks and I was like what when
she's like in a month I was like you
didn't [ __ ] like tell me before she's
like I just knew if I didn't buy it I
was I wasn't gonna go and I was like
we've been together for like two years
you just gotta buy a ticket to Paris and
just go sure enough she went there she
came back she broke up with me holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude we love we love
predictable people man we love
predictable people and I knew it was
gonna happen and it happened if you let
your girlfriend go somewhere for two
weeks out of country you might as well
break up with her for real same goes for
guys girl if you let your dude just
[ __ ] take a trip for two weeks guess
what see you later you might as well
move out right there yeah
when my son grows up that's what I'm
gonna tell him no no no no no dude you
got friend went away for two weeks
find a new girl he's gonna be like but
yeah no no but honestly that's how it's
gonna be
they leave and they [ __ ] find out
some more [ __ ] about life and then they
[ __ ] they do they're gonna be like I
think we grew apart that's the other
thing too don't grow apart with people
bro if you're [ __ ] I don't know it
whatever what am I even talking about at
this point it does you know what we
could sum it up like this sensation wow
that's quick I like it slower better
sensation [ __ ] yeah dude um anyway what
else was I wanted to talk about I don't
even remember so I did the last ad there
we had a [ __ ] another ad today
because of BI eggs remember one [ __ ]
dub C went bi yet III went dub went dub
C from the West Coast connection when bi
H I thought well okay I love dub C he's
one of my fear rappers Westside can get
when he goes Westside could a gank in a
gang bing bing bang and then goes west
side in the back o west side connect
hang bing bing bang hey a you're 40 you
know West see a Foley ania just say it
just say West Side for life n-word
will see a Fillion ear near 40 did I
love it
with Co philia Nia doesn't rhyme
made it rhyme Sebastian izing wrap the
this is a new thing that the last degree
of Kevin Bacon it's a new Spotify
original podcast look man if you don't
like Kevin Bacon I don't want anything
to do with you do you understand Kevin
Bacon is awesome I met him once
at the I don't remember where but it was
behind we were both on the show or
something like that it was like The
Tonight Show or something and he was
nice and his wife was nice and I'm a
Kevin Bacon fan dude so if you don't
like him I don't want anything to do
with you if you do like him and even if
you don't like him I want you to listen
to this it's a fictional comedy podcast
from Spotify in Funny or Die called the
last degree of Kevin Bacon the premise
of the show is that 36 years ago a guy
named Randy B's lo narrowly lost the
starring role in Footloose to Kevin
Bacon and there's been obsessed with him
ever since
so Randy has finally hit his breaking
point and vows to go to LA to kill his
enemy and replace him in the universe
but things don't quite go as planned
obviously through though and when he
when he when he gets there because what
exactly do you do when your mortal enemy
just wants to be his best friend mm-hmm
the last degree of Kevin Bacon is
Spotify is a Spotify original podcast
and you can listen to it for free only
on Spotify it's going to be hilarious so
check it out Funny or Die Spotify they
don't they don't miss um it is actually
crazy how big podcasting has become when
I did it when I started it
my pop when I invented podcast three
years ago and a feud in a few days when
I invented the [ __ ] world of podcast
a few days ago dude there's a guy out
there who's a really successful
community he thinks he invented
podcasting and he didn't and it makes me
[ __ ] laugh so hard I don't want to
tell you who it is but I won't because
I'm good purse anyway dude he [ __ ] uh
yeah but when I invented podcasting
three three years ago it was big and I
got on the [ __ ] bag string but dude I
didn't realize that it was gonna be this
big man like those guys like Rogen and
whoever else is really big it's just
like Jesus Christ talk about bags hope
this live podcast puts us over the top
bro we're like we chart all the time
every week we need more people to listen
this podcast man hey everybody get your
friend to listen to the podcast do the
duty man is this a cult or not man I
mean we're growing but it's a
cult remember it's a cult and cults main
objective is to is to spread the word
cults like Catholicism and Mormonism
those straight-up cults they grow
because they are cults the one we're
we're not a cult we're we're all gonna
kill commit suicide though that those
are [ __ ] [ __ ] cults we're a cult
that's just gonna share ideas and you
know [ __ ] suck in a log cabin near
tallgrass and we're gonna share ideas
but mostly we're gonna [ __ ] suck and
we're gonna eat anything we want that's
my fave we talked about people who need
to unplug we talked about KFC donut
chicken we talked about the BTS video
game people we talked about the [ __ ]
guide rule whatever in the McDonald's
documentary we talked about the corona
virus what else is there to talk about
honestly nothing but do we stop talking
no why because this is the
congratulations podcast we don't stop
just because we're done [ __ ] talking
about the hot issues we talk about the
even hotter issues like when [ __ ] Dan
lied about how it rained and said he was
gonna try and pass it off as that counts
for it being [ __ ] cold tonight
no don't if you have kids look I'm not
gonna let my kid grow up and be that
kind of person all right
I'm not gonna let my kid if I can grow
up and be that kind of person something
happened with the kid and I want to
[ __ ] tell you what happened I can't
remember what the hell it is but it was
funny as [ __ ] dude he [ __ ] rolled
over that's what it was my boy rolled
over it's two weeks in and he rolled the
[ __ ] over do you know when babies roll
over four or five months in dude I have
a bionic kid that kid came out of the
womb and just went beYOU hello dad hello
daddy
hello father oh hey how are you we were
going to name you know yeah my name is
Paige you did you just named yourself
son yes
my name is Tate where is coffee bean
[Laughter]
here's milk no daddy no no no give a
milk crunches it up I don't trunk this
this is for babies so where is coffee
bean what walk through walls outline of
a baby
walks over to [ __ ] coffee bean hello
oh hey you look a little young for I
want coffee okay what would you like
three shots of espresso
I don't drink iced Americanos like my
daddy because that's for [ __ ]
did you know water is added two extra
shots for an Americano I just want the
shots you that'll be that'll be that'll
be 249 baby leans in you I don't have
money yet okay I'm sorry baby it'll be
around the corner
this is a beautiful place now I know
what daddy hangs out here cage here's
your ice there's your three shots of
rice thank you
drinks it that fast and then goes like
this Brazil everything goes
and there goes I am then he goes I am
coffee I will visit daddy back daddy and
mummy back in the hospital
this makes new holes next to the old all
holes in the [ __ ] walls even though
it's even though there's already holes
he wants to make his own new holes
because he
- [ __ ] bad-ass baby and a bionic baby
zoo and they tries to get back in his
mommy's [ __ ] no no you can't do that
I'm sorry no no no you're gonna hurt her
you're gonna hurt her oh I am sorry cage
please I am NOT cage anymore I am coffee
wow that's that's my dream kid for real
and it grows up in listens to [ __ ]
BTS no dents daddy no dents
remember life rips all is the good one
dude tweets you guys are finally getting
what some [ __ ] after I posted that
[ __ ] MacGyver clip man thank you very
much and that's how we get the cult
knowledgeable submit Casey Casey
underscore Amerson Chris Chris Lea how's
the [ __ ] is it it by the way you don't
have to say house of [ __ ] it usually
how [ __ ] is it you say how [ __ ] is it
and something is ass [ __ ] how [ __ ] is
it to try and start a wave at a sporting
event but it doesn't catch on that's
super [ __ ] dude that's super [ __ ]
because you're like kind of doing it and
it doesn't work but you're like oh okay
and you stand up maybe not the whole way
and then you look around looking around
is the most submit [ __ ] checking
anything do what you do and don't look
back be like that guy who [ __ ] walk
in that that movie well whatever that
movie well it happens in every movie but
there's a one movie specifically where
George Clooney is walking away from a
car and a car bomb goes off and he just
keeps walking it's not Sicario but it's
[ __ ] something like that it's called
something like that I mean it was like
[ __ ] from ten years ago what was it
called tyranny or some [ __ ]
that was a George Clooney movie George
George Clooney farted don't give a [ __ ]
that's how we do it and I don't look
back don't look back in anger isn't that
that song he says I guess you know so
not even invested in this podcast
anymore on one fire alright here it is
god it's so weird the [ __ ] that they put
on IMDB now like they've literally put
everything on IMDB not like to have the
Joe Rogan podcast and [ __ ] but
how [ __ ] it goes like this like they
have Nespresso in the name of pleasure
video short George Clooney okay that's
just a commercial for a Nespresso you
need to put that on there here we go
it's after er it was what was it was
after Nespresso cab driver
um no before is after this Nespresso at
the Swap well what the focus is a
trilogy about a Nespresso what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] after up in the air he
did this he did a Nespresso trilogy haha
dude how much money does George Clooney
have I mean goddamn he's got the tequila
that's worth [ __ ] eight billion
dollars and then also he's the head of a
Nespresso the face of Nespresso Jesus
Christ Syriana that's what it was
dude I want to do a movie George Lee was
a movie called Michael Clayton where he
played Michael Clayton I want to do a
movie so bad where it's a drama where
it's the movie title is the guy's name
that's so dope Wow man George Clooney
you know you ever see George Clooney in
like out of sight that guy's so handsome
I'm handsome too dude I'll do the
charity yes I'll do the charity [ __ ]
Bryan Callen Jesus Christ he makes up
charities and then asked me to do man
that takes all the money probably so
it's been how [ __ ] is it to pole-vault
nah I don't know man those are athletes
maybe if they fall I don't know it
depends it always old it also all
depends on how big how [ __ ] it is you
are when you do it this guy got a right
how [ __ ] is it to pole-vault
so I just [ __ ] do what I want to do
whenever I want to do it man
that's how you gotta live your life I'm
pretty much done here but I'm glad we
kept going when we were out of ideas
because that's when we started talking
about the [ __ ] other [ __ ] me me
haven't his son and having him be a
[ __ ] bionic son he rolled over bro
two weeks in he just was like man not my
front door Wow
well you see this video pole-vault fills
this guy's dick [ __ ] rubs up against
the pole vault wow dude tap tempo
vaudeville's that must happen a lot when
you try to pull vault it and then jump
over the rod and then you dick just
[ __ ] sort of flops on it like it's
trying to take a nap real quick look at
this so [ __ ] fast these guys man's
got broke the pole vault for the pole
how do you not break the pole by how
does a pole break at all wow the [ __ ]
snap bro well it's not in two places oh
i feet went over his [ __ ] head well
you can get your legs i can go through
your heart let's see another one
all right you know how many angles oof
i said what was that taking on a [ __ ]
goddamn what happened oh it hit his nuts
don't what are you running with a pole
for anyway this is [ __ ] these old
dude the olympics are so even the
olympics are weird as [ __ ] because
people you don't think would like the
olympics will be like oh no bro i have
so much respect for people who did the
olympics well look what is this [ __ ]
this is something that should be around
in 1820 these are two poles you know we
have bluetooth now the [ __ ] is going on
shotput how far can you throw a heavy
ball are you [ __ ] kidding me
there's like baseball was invented a
hundred years ago and we're still doing
this [ __ ] the olympics throw their
country's men there's billions of people
and we're throwing a ball seven feet
what else is there
we're wrapping it up alright we're done
thank you guys for listening
remember no taunts and also the life
rips hoodie is out look at that dude
look at that beautiful [ __ ] color
text me at eight one eight two three
nine seventy eighty seven and remember
on Friday the live the live
congratulations podcast thing goes up
it's April 29th April 29th is when it
comes but it goes up for sale on Friday
so get your tickets it'll sell out
quickly and come to me and West Palm
Beach come see me in Atlantic City go to
Chris D'Elia
Chris they're calm for all these tickets
by the way and go get that left wrist
hoodie oh and if you do have merged wear
it and the live president remember to
wear the crystal leo marks where the
curse will emerge and most importantly
and other people shirt shows I saw
somebody we're at Burke Chrysler Show I
saw somebody wearing at Bobby Lee show
that's all very important to the story
to spread the word okay thank you very
much and remember you guys you're all
very very sensation
[Music]